FROM THE MULER INVESTIGATION.
AND LINDSAY GRAHAM WILL JOIN US.
STAY WITH US.
>> TONIGHT, MAJOR, MAJOR
PROGRESS ON THREE BIG FRONTS,
EVILLE WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
NORTH KOREA AND THE NOESHGDZS.
THE JUNE 12TH SUMMIT IS BACK.
AND ONLY HOURS AGO, A TOP
LIEUTENANT FROM NORTH KOREA HAND
DELIVERED A NOTE TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT WAS BASIC BUT REPORTEDLY
EXPRESSED KIM JONG-UN'S INTEREST
IN HOLDING THE NUCLEAR SUMMIT
AND THIS IS HOW THE PRESIDENT
REACTED.
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'LL MEET ON JUNE 12TH AND
THINGS LOOK WELL AND A GET TO
KNOW YOU KIND OF SITUATION.
MIKE SPENT TWO DAYS DOING THIS
AND WE ARE GETTING TO KNOW THEIR
PEOPLE WELL.
AND YOU PEOPLE WILL HAVE TO
TRAVEL BECAUSE YOU WILL BE IN
SINGAPORE ON JUNE 12TH.
I THINK IT WILL BE A PROCESS.
I NEVER SAID IT WILL GO IN ONE
MEETING.
IT IS A PROCESS AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE BUILDING AND
THAT IS A PROCESS.
THERE IS YEARS OF PROBLEMS AND
YEARS WAS HATRED BETWEEN SO MANY
DIFFERENT NATIONS AND I THINK
YOU WILL HAVE A POSITIVE RESULT
IN THE END, NOT FROM ONE
MEETING.
WE'LL NOT GO SIGN SOMETHING ON
JUNE 12TH.
WE'LL START A PROCESS AND I TOLD
THEM TODAY, TAKE YOUR TIME AND
WE'LL GO FAST OR SLOWLY.
I THINK THEY WOULD HIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING HAPPEN AND IF WE CAN
WORK THAT OUT, THAT WOULD BE
GOOD.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE KIM IS
COMMITTED TO DENUCLEARIZATION.
>> I THINK HE WANTS TO BE
CAREFUL AND NOT RUN AND DO
THINGS.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS SCHEDULED
TO HOLD A SUMMIT.
AND THEY PLAN TO NEGOTIATE THE
COMPLETE AND UNLATERAL
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREAN
AND THE PROMISE THERE IS HOPE
AND BY THE WAY, YOUR MEDIA SAID
WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
WE'LL HAVE MORE LATER IN THE
SHOW TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, HUGE MASSIVE NEWS ON
THE ECONOMIC FRONT.
THE ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES
IS BOOMING AND WE ARE BREAKING
RECORDS MONTH AFTER MONTH.
IN MAY 200000 JOBS WERE ADDED
AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT AN 18
YEAR LOW.
AND WE HAVE ONLY SEEN A NUMBER
THAT LOW SINCE 1969.
THE METS WON THE WORLD SERIES
AND GET THIS.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT AT
AN ALL- TIME LOW FOR THE FIRST
TIME, 5.9 PERCENT.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AT A 17 YEAR
HIGH.
LOOK AT THAT HEADLINE FROM THE
NEW YORK TIMES.
WE RAN OUT OF THE WORDS TO
DESCRIBE HOW GOOD THE EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS ARE.
AND THIS COUNTRY IN A SO MUCH
BETTER PLACE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AT THE HELM.
AND NUMBERS DO NOT LIKE.
TAKE A TRIP DOWN MEMORY LANE AND
CONTRAST WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
ECONOMIC.
NO GROWTH AND RECORD HIGH OF
DISTRIBUTION OF FOOD STAMPS AND
8 MILLION MORE AMERICANS WERE IN
POVERTY AND THE LOWEST LABORER
PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE THE '
'70s AND HE DOUBLED THE NATIONAL
DEBT.
YEAH, THAT WAS BARAK OBAMA'S
RECORD.
WE'LL GET BACK TO THE MAJOR NEWS
LATER ON IN THE SHOW AND WE'LL
TURN TO OTHER BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS HUGE FROM JOHN SOLOMON.
THE F.B.I.'S EFFORTS TO MONITOR
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ACTUALLY
ORIGINATED BEFORE THE F.B.I.
AUTHORIZED THE COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATION IN
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
AFTER FOREIGN FIGURES CONTACTED
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISORS AND
PROVIDED THE F.B.I. WITH
INFORMATION ON THE COLLUSION.
AND SOME OF THE TRUSTED
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES AND HILLARY
CLINTON SUPPORTER AND IN OTHER
WORDS.
WHAT HAPPEN THIS MEANS, MEMBERS
OF THE DEEP STATE.
CLINTON PSYCHOPHANTS, WERE
FLOODED THE F.B.I. WITH LIES AND
UNVERIFIED AND ANTI- TRUMP
MATERIAL AND THERE'S MORE.
REMEMBER THE LOVE BIRD PAGE AND
STRZOK, JOHN SOLMOAN UNCOVERED
MORE NEW TEXT THAT SHOW THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS LIKELY
VICTIM OFFED -- INVOLVED IN
STEERING OF THE INVESTIGATION.
INCLUDING AS THE F.B.I. WAS
OPENING THE INVESTIGATION IN SO-
CALLED RUSSIAN MEDDLING.
PAGE RIGHTS WE'LL NOT WITHSTAND
THE PRESSURE SOON.
AND PAGE EXPRESSED FEARS THAT
OBAMA WOULD HIJACK OR LEAK
DETAILS TO THE PRESS.
AND PETER STRZOK WROTE THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE IS
RUNNING THIS.
WHAT CAN THEY KNOW?
IT IS TIME TO PUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS ENTIRE TEAM
UNDER OATH.
SARAH CARTER, DETAILING THE
POSSIBLE CONNECTION BETWEEN
A INTERNATIONAL SPYING ALLIIANCE
CALLED THE FIVE I'S.
AND THE REFERENCE TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IS BIGGER.
SOLOMON AND CARTER REPORTED, THE
INVESTIGATION ORIGINATED ABROAD
IN LONDON.
AND NOW THE UNITED KINGDOM IS
A KEY MEMBER OF THE FIVE EYES
ALLIANCE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE A FORMER
COMMUNIST AND FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN CALLING
TRUMP PARINOID FOR EXPRESSING
CONCERN OVER DEEP STATE SPYING.
HE
H
>> HE HAS A PARNOIA AND SECURITY
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION.
HIS TWEETS DO NOT SEEM LIKE THEY
ARE COMING FROM A PERSON MUCH
INNOCENCE AND CONFIDENCE.
MR. TRUMP IS GOING TO TRY TO
DISCREDIT THE F.B.I. AND CIA AND
OTHERS.
BUT NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, THE
AMERICAN JUSTICE SYSTEM IS GOING
TO PREVAIL IN THIS ENDEAVOR TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN COLLABORATING AND
WORKING WITH FOREIGN ACTORS TO
UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE SAME JOHN
BRENNAN WHO TOLD THE WORLD THAT
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE VERY,
VERY WORRIED.
SOUNDS LIKE A DEEP STATE THREAT.
>> I THINK HE IS AFRAID.
>> WHY?
>> ONE CAN SPECULATE MAYBE THE
RUSSIANS HAVE SOMETHING ON HIM
PERSONALLY AND ROLL OUT AND MAKE
LIFE DIFFICULT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO IMPROVE
RELATIONS WITH RUSSIAN.
BUT THE FAWNING ATTITUDE TO MR.
PUTIN AND NOT SAID NEGATIVE
THINGS ABOUT HIM CONTINUES TO
SAY TO ME HE DOES HAVE SOMETHING
TO FEAR.
>> Sean: PUTTING JOHN BRENNAN'S
BLIND HATRED OF TRUMP ASIDE.
WE SHOW THAT THE DEEP STATE IS
STARTING TO CRACK.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL KIM
STROSSEL.
THERE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES WITH
THE PAPADOPOULOS AND THE ALLEGED
INFORNLANT PUBLICLY CONTRADICTED
THE F.B.I.'S OWN CLAIMS THAT THE
LOW LEVEL TRUMP ADVISOR
DISCUSSED THE HACKED DEMOCRATIC
EMAILS.
THE INFAMOUS MEETING BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP JUNIOR AND
A RUSSIAN LOBBYER AND WE HAVE
NEW INFORMATION, A TRANSCRIPT
FROM A SENATE HEARING THAT THE
RUSSIAN AMERICAN LOBBYIST TO
PERSONALLY KNOWING HILLARY
CLINTON AND SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WORKED IN HER CAMPAIGN.
WHAT WAS SOMEONE WHO KNEW
HILLARY CLINTON DOING IN THAT
MEETING?
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE AND GETS MORE
INSANE EVERY DAY.
WE'LL HAVE MORE LATER IN THE
SHOW.
AND TURN TO THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND SAID COMEY
SHOULD BE FIRED AND SIGNED THE
LAST FISA WARRANT THAT CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR AND USED
FUNNELED MONEY FROM THE LAW FIRM
AND RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES TO
MANIPULATE YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
LAST NIGHT WE SHOW YOU HOW
ROSENSTEIN'S CLEAR CONFLICTS WAS
INTEREST ON THE RUSSIA PROBE.
HE IS WITNESS A IN THE WHOLE
INVESTIGATION.
AND HE'S THE ONE THAT APPOINT
MUELLER AND THERE ARE CALLS FOR
ROD ROSENSTEIN TO RECUSE
HIMSELF.
THAT INCLUDES SENATOR LINDSAY
GRAHAM.
DO YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF
A POTENTIAL WITNESS IN THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION REGARDING
THE FIRING OF DIRECTOR COMEY BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
IF NOT, WHY NOT?
HE RECOMMENDED IT, YEAH, HE IS
A WITNESS.
AND IF SO, YOU SHOULD RECUSE
YOURSELF WITH OVERSOCIETY OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THANKFULLY FINALLY SOMEONE
SAPING WHAT WE ARE SAYING AND
CALLING FOR OVER AND OVER FOR
MONTHS.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN, IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
WE KNOW THE ANSWERS AND THEN
RECUSE YOURSELF AND GET OUT OF
THE WAY.
YOU ARE THE MOST CONFLICTED
PERSON IN ALL OF THIS.
NOT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS AND GREAT NEWS FOR ME
TONIGHT.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
REMEMBER WHEN CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
DON'T MESS WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THEY WILL GET.
THERE IS A BOOK ON AMAZON POINT
COMCALLED "KILLING THE DEEP
STATE."  REMEMBER THE GROUP
AGAINST JOHN KERRY, VETS FOR
TRUTHS.
THAT I SEAN HANNITY IS THE NEXT
TARGET OF THE DEEP STATE.
WOW, IT IS GREAT TO KNOW THAT
CORRUPT OFFICIALS WITH THE BACKS
AGAINST THE WALL AND DESPERATE
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATE THINGS AND
ARE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE ARE NOW GOING AFTER
ME?
OKAY.
REALLY?
SO SADLY AFTER ALL WE HAVE
LEARNED, NOW WE HAVE JEROME'S
REDICTION.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
WE THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
ARE WE THE FORMER SOVIET UNION